it's an unusual evening in bonds
Beethoven Hall pavo European the German
chamber Philharmonic Braman are
performing a concert version of Fidelio
the only opera composed by Ludwig von
Beethoven
it's not really an opera it's not really
a place as a reversing spill it has a
very large and long sections of spoken
text in the middle which for example
motor toppers also had and yet it it it
doesn't quite feel natural on stage and
it doesn't entirely sit well on the
concert stage concertante version and
finding that right medium between
between telling the story but also
letting the music tell the story creates
a lot of questions the performance of
Fidelio is one of the high points of
this year's bond beethoven festival and
not only in terms of the music for the
last seven years selected concerts have
been video linked to a square downtown
this year the live video cast for a
crowd of some 3,000 people to the Market
Square and bond
and kids need it was gnarly down there I
would have had to pay a lot of money to
hear the concert in the Beethoven hall
this way i can afford to enjoy a great
concert in a great atmosphere of this
crap meds freshman i couldn't afford a
ticket that's why I'm here I'm gonna be
to put up with the cold hi Joe Kenda
Cato's the people miss field for us
Beethoven is a highlight in highlight
through the camera we see the faces
close-up if I was sitting in the
auditorium far away from the musicians I
wouldn't see their facial expressions
and I can imagine it wouldn't come
across as well but I need to start
what's ahead mine and internationally
renowned soprano can be heard in the
role of Matt Selena for her singing in
an opera without a stage set or costumes
is an exception Mac police assignment
it's on but one doesn't seem to miss
much and one is it misled by the wrong
things either popka linked to be of
course i love the opera and musical
theater and i'd love to act about but
here concentrating on the essence and a
concert performance of an opera is
fascinating and enriching there's fund
on some heightened
the videocast in downtown bond is a new
tradition introduced only in 2007
Deutsche Welle has been the festival's
media partner from the beginning and
always presents an accompanying program
lasting several hours
then when it's public cooing often I
ever live transmission broadcast by us
then obviously first and foremost that
helps to make us better known among the
German public and it also makes clear
that were anchored here in society and
connected with it conductor paavo järvi
and the german chamber philharmonic
bremen as orchestra in residence have
shaped the program of the bait olin
festival for years madad also come along
with in with the german chamber
philharmonic Bremen which has now also
performed the Fidelio with Parvati we've
managed to create our own culture of
interpretation today anyone who
interprets these symphonies here or
other works by Beethoven has to measure
themselves against this interpretation
Beethoven's Fidelio evokes the spirit of
the French Revolution but it fits well
with this year's model of the Beethoven
festival metamorphosis